our voicemail number is two one nine to
david p here is a voicemail that i
received oh man pac-man i really wish
you did a show today and we're non
vacation and wherever the hell you were
because oh I cannot wait to hear the
butter commentary about Trump's
appearance on the Jimmy Fallon show it's
gonna be so great to hear how much how
much tripping I bet it was more
triggering than World War two going on
in in your ear underwear man you're
probably so mad weren't you is it let me
guess I guess we got a boycott Jimmy
Fallon Jimmy found the races is that
right yeah man I can't wait all right
that's all of the SE llaman lovely you
have a lovely day pack that have a
lovely day thank you yeah listen this is
the Louisiana troll not to be confused
with the Kansas troll or the San Antonio
troll neither of whom we've heard from
recently by the way uh I hate to keep
you waiting Louisiana troll but uh I
really don't care about that interview
that Jimmy Fallon did with Trump some
people were angry saying Jimmy Fallon is
sort of like uh uh catering to trump
easy I don't care I do not care I've got
bigger things to worry about including
of the the the debates that are going on
the election bigger things I'm not gonna
be commenting on Jimmy Fallon so you
keep waiting buddy on the bonus show
today more stories from my trip and much
more discussion of the UH post-election
david pakman show a lot of people
writing in saying David what are you
going to do on the show after the
election is over and i will explain why
that is a very very silly question david
pakman.com slash membership the one
place to sign up